he's Ross Tucker he used to play in the
NFL and now he's a radio host big-time
radio host
he's got the podcast it's the Ross
Tucker football podcast you can hear him
on Sirius XM Westwood One he's got two
college games this weekend Holy Cross at
Colgate and he also works for Westwood
One on Monday Night Football hi Ross how
are you
dan I'm great but I guess I'm not real
happy with you right now okay I am ready
to go what do you have for me
so I mean you had major oral surgery
yesterday yes today would have been a
perfect day to take a day off so that I
could actually come up there and fill in
it's been like months since I've had a
chance to see my guys and fill in plus
then it's a meet Friday and you can't
even eat the meat because of your mouth
I mean what are you trying to put it
what are you trying to prove it it what
kind of Iron Man deal are you doing you
can't let me come up for one day after
you have a mate you almost died
yesterday I know I know you're right how
many times did you check in with Paulie
yesterday to see if I was going to be
able to answer the call Paulie emailed
me like Tuesday or Wednesday we might
need you Friday okay I'm in then he
emailed me back Wednesday we don't need
you we're good okay then yesterday she
texted me and Paulie only reaches out if
there's a chance that he needs me to
fill it in for you so he texts me like
what's up I'm like you tell me I mean we
got on the phone and he said so Dan
we're not exactly sure I was like what
can you ask
I'd love to come up there I'd love to
fill in for him but I don't I don't know
if I want to drive you know three and a
half hours to Connecticut if you know
just to be on for five minutes if Dan's
able to able to answer the bell like I
knew you would be were you rooting for
me not to be able to show up today
I wouldn't say rooting for you not to be
able to show up but if there were some
complications with the surgery that
might have benefited me not nothing
serious but just enough to put you out
of commission for today
Friday's kind of my thing I'm a meathead
yeah me I'm meathead james van der beek
I got some football questions for you
who starts for the Arizona Cardinals Sam
Bradford who starts for the Buffalo No
oh go ahead who starts for the Buffalo
Bills Nathan Peterman starts the opener
but I'm glad you brought this up this
really bothers me Dan you know I don't
you saw where first of all AJ McCarron
was not good last night and second of
all in the fourth quarter he was in the
fourth quarter he was yes you're right
you're right you're right you're right
it was legendary he was legendary in the
fourth quarter of a fourth preseason
game according to AJ but what spurs on
to me about that Dan is yeah after the
game somebody said Shawn McDermott you
know his AJ McCarron still in the
running to be the starting quarterback
and Shawn McDermott answered absolutely
and so this bothers me because either
number one
he's just being so dishonest it's
ridiculous because there's no way AJ
McCarron's in the running he's been hurt
he hasn't played well they have a top-10
pick and Josh Allen's been a lot of nice
things and by the way Nathan Peterman
has been like flawless
so either McDermott's just doing your
coach thing trying to keep it up in the
air for the next opponent which i think
is stupid or maybe he is really
considering AJ McCarron which is even
worse that would be asinine Peterman has
been really good this preseason you have
a top-10 pick there would be no reason
to start AJ McCarron in their first game
anything else you want to get off your
chest
one other thing yeah how much do you
know about this Australian left tackle
for the Eagles Jordan mulatto
I only know I saw the story today on him
that was it I'm like obsessed with this
guy he's never played football before he
played rugby in Australia he's 6 9 3
the the Eagles throughout him in the
seventh round Danna I watched every snap
last night I'm sitting in my bed eating
pretzels and peanut butter watching
Hackenberg throw pics and fumble and
this left tackle then he is going to be
a Pro Bowl left tackle it's the darndest
thing and he actually reminds me of
Jason Peters because I was there in
Buffalo literally the day they moved
Peters from tight end the left tackle
and nobody could get by him and I was so
upset because I've been trying to do
this in sixth grade and Peters was
better than me in five minutes that's
what this my lot of guys like I mean he
is really really impressive for a guy
that was his fourth football game ever
last night and bullrushes when they're
trying to run into him it's like they're
hitting a brick wall when they try to go
inside he's totally washing him down I'm
borderline obsessed with this guy at
this point I mean he's he's 21 years old
about 20 23 in 2020 I think he'll be a
Pro Bowl tack on the NFL for the Eagles
what's it like to get cut a hole but it
depends on the year I mean it's always
bad but a couple years I kind of knew it
was coming so it's still hurt but it
wasn't that as bad but actually the last
time I got cut was the worst I started
the Browns traded for me the vaunted
conditional seventh round pick I was in
New England the Browns traded for me and
I started the last three preseason games
at center this is when latrell's Bentley
tore his knee up and I went to bed that
night I had my phone turned off my
wife's like is there any chance I said
no I'm starting like I'm gonna start the
opener next week against the Saints had
my phone on silent you know we went out
that night whatever nine o'clock I roll
over I look at my phone and there's a
missed call from for 400 or tu-16 or
whatever they like I I mean I my heart
sank
I felt nauseous I listened to the
message that that was really really
tough and that was my fourth and final
time getting cut and I was
most devastated by that and I went in I
went right to Phil savage to GM I said
what's the deal you traded look first of
all what are you doing and you wouldn't
tell me what they were doing but they
ended up trading for Hank for Ellie that
day who they thought was better than me
which is fine but he wouldn't tell me
that so he was acting like they were
going with like some rookie I was like
no you're not
this is ridiculous and I said Phil you
traded for me and I came in I played
average that's what I do you trade it
for average I gave you average like I
just I I was that was very literally my
father-in-law said to my wife because we
had two cars there make sure you drive
behind Ross because I was that I was
that upset well I'm curious what you
thought of what Tony Romo said that once
Brady's done it's all about Aaron
Rodgers then after that Sam darn 'old
will be the man yeah well I'm a huge
darn old fan he was my number one guy
coming out I I was the color guy for the
u.s. army ball three years ago and
thought he was awesome but like Tony
Romo heard of Carson Wentz or just show
him Austin
maybe something happen to those guys I'm
not aware of me Kersten went should have
been the MVP of the league last year if
he didn't get hurt I would have been in
fact he definitely would have been and
deshaun Watson took the league by storm
like we've almost never seen before so I
don't I don't really know what what Tony
was saying there it's like you forgot
about those two guys maybe because they
were injured so I'm not ready to say
that I would say right now it's Brady
that it's Aaron Rodgers then the next
group would be whence Watson and maybe
one of these rookies you know ends up
being among that mix but it's once and
Watson based on what we've seen and you
went off on on Brett Hundley when
Seattle traded for Brett Hundley with
the Packers and I was saying that I saw
Brett Hundley played the preseason game
of the Packers against the Raiders and I
thought he looked okay and you said he's
horrible and could Seattle have seen any
of the games that he played last year
wait why are you killing though my boy
Brett Hundley so Dan okay
here's the thing he's looked at every
preseason all right
last year as part of my duties for west
of 1 I called five Packers games four of
them were humming home games in Green
Bay and I never say this about guys I
know how hard it is I was not a good
player I was an average player and at
times I know what it was like to play
bad in a game he was awful man like he
was awful and the idea of giving up a
draft pick for that a six round pick I
just don't understand it I mean there's
gonna be guys that get cut
maybe RG three or like Osweiler or paksa
I don't know there's gonna be guys that
get cut that you can just sign for the
minimum and have him back up Russell
Wilson to trade anything for Hundley
after how he played last year to me is
like fun office malpractice the guy was
awful I never say that but he was
terrible all right you got it off your
chest yeah I'm kind of fired up today
because I should be there I should be
there but you're pulling the whole hero
game I remember after you caught the one
ball off the ball cannon you had a cut
like on your eye or ear and you kept
doing it yeah I don't know what you're
trying to prove in terms of toughness
well I learned from a good friend of
mine named Tommy and tv-tv
12 just taught me about just be tough
just you know you get hit you get back
up you get hit you get back up and and
I'm glad that tom told me you know
that's the approach to take that's all
and you know Giselle likes it as well
she's already text me today say very
impressed with you Danny and I
appreciate that
is there any way Dan you can get some
meat on the right side your left side I
don't think it's gonna happen but can
you take a couple bites on the right
side I'm gonna try because it smells so
good
but it looks like I have a ton of meat
in my jaw anyways or wadded tobacco or
something in there I mean it's it I'm
deformed here I'm deformed it's really
really impressive it's actually
impressive that you're finally who gets
who
wisdom teeth removed at your age what's
the deal with that I had so much wisdom
they said I've got to take some of this
out because it's not fair to everybody
else and I said all right you can take
one but I wasn't gonna let him take all
the other ones all I remember about
getting my wisdom teeth removed is I
think I was 19 or 20 and my buddy's dad
was actually the orthopedic surgeon and
I remember he counted down I shut my
eyes oh I felt like Dan I don't know
what I don't know what it is that they
give you but I blinked my eyes and woke
up like I did not feel like I was out
for an hour I felt like I blinked my
eyes that's all I did and it was over
and I was up and I was asking him and
his son if I could get some more of that
stuff because that was amazing I didn't
even want to do a local like I did
laughing gas but I said look I can get
through with just laughing again they
didn't put me out
yeah I'd said no real men don't get put
out so they gave me gave me a local and
did laughing guy so you know I just
wanted to experience it and plus I
thought I could keep the doctor company
and that's really what I was trying to
do I was trying to help him a little bit
but Wow yeah well I was a Division one
college football player when they
knocked me out so you're tougher than I
was as a Division one college football
player at 19 years old said I was out
but Ross well I liked being at Ross you
went to an Ivy League school I mean
that's smart but not tough okay okay
okay all right have a great weekend Ross
I'll let you know when I'm feeling a
little under the weather yes please do
thank you that's Ross Tucker Tucker
fills in for me occasionally great sense
humor good spirit about four more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show at
you
[Music]